calorimetry refers to the measurement of
heat flow and a device that's used to
measure heat flow is called a
calorimeter
an easy way to make a calorimeter is to
use two coffee cups so at the base here
we have one coffee cup and then we can
also use another coffee cup as a loose
fitting lid and since this top coffee
cup is loose fitting our calorimeter is
exposed to the constant pressure of the
atmosphere therefore we could use this
coffee cup calorimeter for constant
pressure calorimetry
other components of our calorimeter
include some water
and then we also have a stir bar to stir
up the water
and a thermometer to measure the
temperature change of the water
let's say we have
150.0 grams of water at an initial
temperature of 25.0 degrees celsius
next let's take a block of copper
120.0 grams of it and let's heat up that
block of copper to
100.0 degrees celsius
once the copper has reached that
temperature we add the copper block to
our calorimeter
here we can see the copper block has
been added to the calorimeter and since
the copper is at a higher temperature
than the water heat flows from the
copper block to the water and therefore
the temperature of the water will
increase which we will we will see on
the thermometer so we'll see the
temperature increase on the thermometer
heat is transferred from the copper
block to the water until thermal
equilibrium has been reached and we know
when thermal equilibrium has been
reached by looking at the thermometer
and measuring the highest temperature
that's reached let's say the final
temperature is equal to 30.0
degrees celsius so at thermal
equilibrium both the piece of copper
both the copper block and the water are
at the same final temperature
next let's calculate the heat gained by
the water by using the equation q is
equal to mc delta t
so q is what we're trying to calculate
the heat gained by the water m is the
mass of the water which is
150.0 grams so we can write in
150.0 grams
c is the specific heat of water which is
4.18
joules
per
gram degree celsius
and delta t is the change in the
temperature which would be the final
temperature so tf minus the initial
temperature ti
the final temperature of the water is
30.0 degrees celsius and the initial
temperature of the water
was 25.0 degrees celsius so 30.0 minus
25.0
is equal to 5.0 degrees celsius so we
can write that in
and next we look at units and see what
cancels out here so the grams cancel out
uh degrees celsius cancels out and we're
left with joules as our unit so q
is equal to uh when we go to two
significant figures this is positive
3.1
times 10 to the third joules
the positive sign
means that this was the energy gained by
the water
next let's do the same calculation for
copper so we're trying to find q
the mass of the copper was 120.0
grams so we can plug that in
the specific heat of copper is .39
joules per gram
degree celsius
and let's think about the change in the
temperature of the copper the final
temperature of the copper was 30.0
degrees celsius
and the initial temperature of the
copper was 100.0
degrees celsius so the change in the
temperature would be 30.0 minus 100.0
which of course is negative 70.0
so let's plug in negative 70.0
degrees celsius
once again we see what cancels for our
units uh grams will cancel degrees
celsius will cancel and our answer will
be in joules
so q is equal to
using two significant figures negative
three point
negative three point three times ten to
the third
joules
and the negative sign so this negative
sign
means this is the energy that was lost
by the copper
next let's look at these two numbers
that we got from our calculations let's
think about the magnitude of these two
numbers if our coffee cup calorimeter
were a perfect insulator the magnitude
of these two numbers would be the same
so it could be something like 3.3 times
10 to the third joules for both of them
but since these two numbers are not the
same all right we can see that we've
lost more more heat from the copper than
we've gained in terms of energy for the
water which means we could have lost
some of the energy to the environment so
not not all of the heat was transferred
directly to the water some of it could
have escaped our coffee cup calorimeter
next let's think about calorimetry for a
chemical reaction so before we do that
let's review some terms for
thermodynamics
so the system is the part of the
universe that we are studying so in the
case of a chemical reaction the
reactants and the products make up the
system the surroundings are everything
else are ever everything else which
would include the water in the
calorimeter
the coffee cup itself the thermometer
the environment outside so the
surroundings are everything else and
finally the universe would be the system
plus the surroundings
so the reactants and the products make
up the system so that's what the s
stands for here in in our calorimeter
that's our system let's say we run a
reaction and in the reaction heat is
given off
so in that case heat would flow from the
system to the surroundings and so the
temperature of the water would increase
so we would see that as the temperature
increases on the thermometer
next we could calculate the heat gained
by the water by using our q is equal to
m c
delta t equation and let's say q is
equal to positive
1.0 times
10 to the second joules
the positive sign means that the water
gained energy
if we assume a perfect transfer of heat
from the system to the surroundings if
the surroundings gained positive 1.0
times 10 to the second joules that means
the system must have lost negative 1.0
times 10 to the second joules
so the same magnitude but we changed the
sign here because if we're talking about
the energy lost by the system it's the
same in magnitude but opposite in sine
next remember that our lid over here is
loose fitting which makes this constant
pressure calorimetry
and therefore this heat that was
transferred is the heat that's
transferred at constant pressure so we
can write a subscript p in here so qp
the heat transfer to constant pressure
is the definition for the change in the
enthalpy delta h so we can write that qp
is equal to delta h
and when delta h is negative we're
talking about an exothermic
an exothermic reaction
so when a reaction is exothermic heat is
transferred from the system to the
surroundings and therefore we see an
increase in the temperature of the water
finally let's think about an endothermic
reaction in an endothermic reaction heat
is transferred from the surroundings to
the system so here we can show heat
flowing from the surroundings to the
system since energy is leaving the
surroundings
the temperature of the water will
decrease for an endothermic reaction
and since heat is being transferred to
the system we can go ahead and write
heat over here
we can go ahead and write heat on the
reactant side
and
delta h would be positive for an
endothermic reaction so for an
endothermic reaction energy is
transferred from the surroundings to the
system and therefore the temperature of
the water will decrease